yesterday the American Academy of
Pediatrics along with the American
Medical Association and the Children's
Hospital Association collectively
published a letter which was addressed
to the Department of Justice and which
calls for me to be prosecuted and thrown
in federal prison so just another day at
the office I suppose but it's not just
me being targeted of course lives of
tick tock Chris rufo and others are all
are are on The Hit List and the letter
doesn't mention Us by name but it
doesn't have to besides there's always
the media which is here to sort of fill
in the blanks for them which they rely
on so as the hill reports quote leading
Health Care organizations in a sent a
letter uh Monday to attorney general
Merrick Garland and called on the
Department of Justice to investigate
recent threats of violence against
Physicians hospitals and families that
provide gender affirming care to
transgender youth the organizations
collectively represent more than 270 000
positions and more than 220 Children's
Hospitals Nationwide medical facilities
that provide gender affirming Healthcare
to transgender miners have recently been
the targets of online attacks and the
letter says a few high-profile users are
intentionally spreading false and
misleading information conservative
commentators including Tucker Carlson
and Matt Walsh as well as right-wing
social media accounts with large
followings like lives of tick tock have
alleged that doctors are abusing
children by prescribing puberty blockers
and gender affirming hormones
now notice the verbiage there first of
all we have uh we're we're told that
we've alleged
that doctors are abusing children by
prescribing puberty blockers and gender
affirming hormones
so which part is alleged that doctors
are prescribing these drugs or that
they're abusing children by prescribing
the drugs so as always the phrasing is
intentionally vague and misleading and
also false we should we should note we
are not alleging that doctors are giving
sterilization and castration drugs to
kids they're doing more than that too
they're mutilating kids physically
through surgery we're not alleging that
we're reporting it we're observing it
we're uh we're pointing it out
it is a fact that this is happening and
we are calling attention to the fact
we're also not alleging that these drugs
constitute abuse again this is a fact
according to any coherent definition of
the word abuse we are um arguing that
this practice is abusive and we are
presenting evidence and information to
support that claim
but we know of course that the other
side will not honestly engage with us
because they cannot they can only lie
and mislead and if that fails they can
call upon their powerful friends to have
a silence which brings us to the actual
letter which begins quote
dear attorney general Garland on behalf
of the American Academy of Pediatrics
the American Medical Association and the
Children's Hospital Association
collectively representing more than 270
000 positions and more than 220
Children's Hospitals we write to urge
you to investigate the organization's
individuals and entities coordinating
provoking and carrying out bomb threats
and threats of personal violence against
children's hospitals and Physicians
across the U.S so take special note of
the words individuals and provoking now
if they had simply called upon the doj
to investigate the people carrying out
the alleged bomb threats
I'd have no complaint about that yes if
there's a bomb threat investigated
but they also want the federal
government to bring the hammer down on
the individuals who they claim are
provoking these alleged threats
and it's already been made very clear
that anyone who reports on what these
hospitals are doing or criticizes them
for or says that they should not be
doing what they're doing
is inciting violence even if they never
call for violence or say anything that
could be remotely construed as an
encouragement for violence just by
talking about it they are inciting
violence so it's clear who's being
referred to here now continuing from
Boston to Akron to Nashville to Seattle
Children's Hospitals academic Health
Systems and Physicians are being
targeted and threatened for providing
evidence-based Health Care these attacks
have not only made it difficult and
dangerous for institutions of practices
to provide this care they've also
disrupted many other services to family
seeking care these coordinated attacks
threaten federally protected rights to
health care for patients and their
families the attacks are rooted in an
intentional campaign of disinformation
where a few high-profile users on social
media share false and misleading
information targeting individual
Physicians and hospitals resulting in a
rapid escalation of threats harassment
and disruption of care across multiple
jurisdictions organizations have called
on technology companies to do more to
prevent this practice on digital
platforms and we now urge your office to
take Swift action to investigate and
prosecute all organizations individuals
and entities responsible
well there it is high profile users on
social media are targeting hospitals
which results in threats this is
happening in places like Boston and they
mentioned Nashville
they say these individuals should be
investigated and prosecuted and this is
all according to three of the largest
and wealthiest medical organizations in
the entire world
now the left is losing their faith but
we're not and the core part of that
faith is prayer I talk a lot about
stressful things all day and you might
feel a little bit overwhelmed with where
the country is going if you're like me
but I've got good news hallow could help
you find some peace and hope rooted not
in the government or its institutions
but in God hallow has over at 5 000
audio guided prayers meditations and
peaceful Christian music including the
rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg the Bible in a year with father
Mike Schmitz had so much more Hello
helps you build a daily routine and a
habit of Prayer
it helps me to prayer meditate pray
meditate and sleep better as well it's a
huge part of my daily routine I think it
will be for you as well if you go and
get an exclusive three-month trial of
hallow at hello.com Matt Walsh that's
hello.com Matt Walsh reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hello today
so make no mistake here
they are explicitly stating that high
profile people quote unquote who
criticize their practices
should go to federal prison that's what
you're asking for when you when you're
asking for the federal government to
arrest somebody
um they're not just saying that it
should happen they're actively calling
on the Attorney General to make it
happen
they intend to use the force of the
federal government
to silence us permanently if they can
so let me make a few points here
first of all we are once again accused
of sharing false and misleading
information to use their phrasing
and yet once again they fail to provide
any specific example of this supposed
misinformation
so I've been told a million times that
what I'm saying is misinformation what
lives with Tick Tock are saying is
misinformation Chris rufo everybody what
we're all saying is misinformation no
one's ever specified what exact part is
misinformation
they don't do that because they know
Phil full well that everything we've
reported about these hospitals is
factual and supported by extensive
documentation and evidence We Lay It All
Out
they also know full well that we're not
saying anything that these medical
establishments have not already said
themselves so the hospitals say we
provide these services and then we say
uh look these hospitals just said they
provide these services
and then we get accused of
misinformation
the real misinformation here is the
claim that we are spreading
misinformation
that itself is misinformation it's also
defamatory
okay the AAP and the AMA they are lying
about us with the direct and explicit
intent of causing us harm
that's defamation second
um I'm I'm obviously well aware that the
people who go around all day crying
about fascism and tyranny really have no
idea what these terms mean nor do they
care
but if we were living in some alternate
reality where such people had integrity
then maybe they'd be concerned about
this actual real life example of
authoritarian tyranny happening in their
midst because to State again these
extraordinarily well-funded and Powerful
medical organizations are attempting to
use the arm of the state to suppress
intimidate and punish their critics and
not just the state
see we see here the whole multi-headed
Hydra monstrosity come into view this is
the medical establishment
summoning the federal government and
also the big Tech Monopoly to crush
anyone who opposes it
and in this effort they also get a big
assist from the corporate media so this
is the this is the system the corporate
media the government medical
establishment big Tech
this is the system it's the thing the
left used to pretend to Rage Against
um yesterday there's a woman named
Brooke binkowski who's the managing
editor of a sham fact-checking outfit
and she tweeted at me in support of the
aap's speech depression tactic she said
freedom of speech isn't freedom from
consequences for that speech that's the
part you Bootleggers always forget until
it's too late cry more
yet of course the medical establishment
is trying to get the state involved
and Free Speech does most certainly mean
that your speech should be free from
government reprisal if that's not what
Free Speech means Then I then I don't
know what Free Speech means
which is what people like uh you know
that's what people like Brooke really
really mean by the way they don't think
that Free Speech means anything they
don't care about they're too cowardly to
say it
but it's her usage of the term boot
licker that really interests me because
she is here coming to the defense of the
federal government the medical
establishment big Tech and the corporate
media she is defending all of the most
powerful institutions in our society and
while doing so accusing me of being a
bootlegger
no I'm not I'm I'm the one that they are
trying to stomp under their Boot Hill
okay me and anyone else that opposes
what the medical establishment is doing
to kids we're the ones being stomped or
or that they're attempting to stop
she is the one kneeling and kissing
their feet
she and everybody else on the left
they uh Rage Against the Machine these
days by bowing before it
but will they be successful
the AAP wants Garland's goons to break
down our doors and cart us away in the
middle of the night at gunpoint and um
is that actually going to happen
maybe I mean you can't rule it out
it's exactly what they just did to that
pro-life activists up in Pennsylvania
and if they'll do it on that issue to a
guy like that
um then they'll do it here so you know
it's it's it is possible I will say that
right so it's certainly a possibility
I can't control that or predict it
but what I can say is this what I've
been saying all along which is that I
truly believe that gender ideology is
one of the greatest evils in human
history
I don't say that lightly it's what I
actually that's that's what I believe
um and I believe that those of us who
are in this fight are called to be here
this is our vocation this is our mission
there's nothing they could threaten
that would make me back down from this
fight you're gonna have to throw me in
prison or kill me because that's the
only way you'll shut me up
I would actually rather be dead than
surrender to this madness
for me it's as simple as that
and that will do it for us today we move
over to the members block I hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow or
I'll see you at Catholic University
tonight Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]